Vamos a repasar un poco lo que ya sabemos
acerca de las leyes de los exponentes.
Si nosotros tenemos por ejemplo,
3, esto elevado a la potencia número 2,
y a esto lo multiplicamos por 3,
esto a su vez,
elevado a la potencia número 3.
Entonces, ¿qué obtenemos?
Bueno, pues es que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 3 elevado al cuadrado,
lo podemos visualizar de la siguiente manera,
como 3 por 3,
y a esto lo estamos multiplicando...
lo estamos multiplicando por 3 elevado al cubo,
pero 3 elevado al cubo lo podemos ver como
3 por 3, por 3.
Ahora date cuenta que tengo 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
veces al 3, multiplicándose por sí mismo,
por lo tanto, puedo concluir que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 3...
que 3 elevado a la potencia 2...
2...
que son estos 2 de aquí...
justo estos 2 de aquí
más...
3 que son justo estos 3 de aquí..
estos 3 de aquí...
de tal manera, que esto me va a quedar exactamente
lo mismo que 3 elevado a la quinta potencia.
Y si te das cuenta esto es cierto por que aquí tenemos,
5 veces al 3 multiplicándose por sí mismo.
Estamos diciendo que esto es cierto.
Bueno, pero esto ya lo sabíamos.
Ahora, lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo, es pensar un poco y que pensemos
¿qué significa tener 3...
3 elevado a la potencia... se me ocurre -2?
¿A qué me refiero cuando tengo al
3 elevado a la potencia -2?
Y bueno nosotros podemos pensar
bajo esta misma perspectiva,
utilizando una suma de potencias
y de aquí poder concluir algo acerca de 3 elevado a la - 2.
Piénsalo por un momento.
Ahora, ¿qué te parece si nosotros hacemos un pequeño experimento?
Vamos a tomarnos, 3 elevado a la potencia 2...
elevado a la potencia 2...
y a esto, a su vez,
lo voy a multiplicar por 3, elevado a la potencia - 2
¿Qué voy a obtener de esto?
Bueno, yo sé que justo por esta misma propiedad
que tengo aquí arriba,
esto es exactamente lo mismo que, 3 elevado
y las potencias se suman, elevado a la potencia 2,
más...
déjame ponerlo con otro color,
más a la potencia -2
- 2
Ok.
Y esto es exactamente lo mismo,
que 3 elevado a la 2 más -2,
es 3 elevado a la 0,
esto es 3 elevado a la potencia 0,
y nosotros también sabemos que hay una propiedad
o una regla de los exponentes,
que nos dice que todo número,
todo número elevado a la 0 siempre es 1.
Esto es igual a 1, ok,
y esto me va a servir bastante,
porque entonces...
y déjame agarrar esta parte de aquí.
Si yo tomo justo esta parte de aquí,
estoy diciendo que 3 elevado...
déjame copiarla y pegarla...
que 3 elevado a la potencia 2,
por 3 elevado a la potencia -2
esto es exactamente igual,
a 1...
esto es exactamente igual a 1,
ó dicho de otra manera,
y ahora puedo agarrar éste de aquí,
¿1ué te parece si divido todo?
Voy a dividir todo,
tanto la parte izquierda, como la parte derecha de esta igualdad
entre 3 elevado al cuadrado...
entre 3 elevado al cuadrado....
esta parte la voy a dividir entre 3 elevado al cuadrado,
y la otra parte también
la voy a dividir entre 3 elevado al cuadrado,
y déjame poner que estamos dividiendo,
así que para esto voy a hacerte aquí una línea
y aquí otra línea,
y ahora date cuenta,
que este 3 elevado al cuadrado, multiplica,
y a su vez divide y por lo tanto se pueden cancelar,
éste se puede cancelar con éste
y me va a quedar un resultado sorprendente,
que 3
elevado a una potencia -2,
esto es exactamente lo mismo...
es exactamente lo mismo,
que 1... que 1
esto dividido...
dividido entre 3 elevado al cuadrado,
entre 3 elevado al cuadrado,
y esto está sorprendente,
porque ya tengo una forma de ver a 3 elevado a la - 2, que es justo lo que nos preguntábamos hace rato.
Utilizando esta propiedad que tengo aquí arriba de la suma de
exponentes,
utilizando una propiedad de los exponentes
que nosotros ya sabíamos,
puedo concluir justo esta expresión que tengo aquí,
que 3 elevado a la - 2,
es lo mismo que 1 entre 3 elevado al cuadrado.
De este paso pasé a éste de aquí...
Y bueno,
nosotros podemos leer que 3 elevado a la -2
es exactamente lo mismo
que 1 entre 3 elevado a la versión positiva de -2,
y es justo lo que quiero ver
en el siguiente vídeo on mucha calma.
Vamos a demostrar que 3 elevado a cualquier potencia negativa es exactamente lo mismo
que 1 entre 3 elevado a esa misma potencia
pero positiva,
su versión positiva y para eso vamos a utilizar
justo lo que tenemos acá arriba, y que ya sabemos.
Que cuando yo tengo una base elevada a una potencia
por otra base elevada a otra potencia distinta,
o la misma,
esto es exactamente lo mismo
que la base elevada a la suma de las potencias,
y con esto voy a poder llegar a una expresión equivalente
para 3 ó para alguna base
elevada a una potencia negativa.
Así que por este vídeo lo único que te puedo encargar
es que pienses un poco más
en el significado de 3 elevado a la -2.
Hasta la próxima.